there was a point where I was excited
about embracer group entering the games
industry and swiping up all these
Studios because I thought well they
clearly have a ton of ambition to make a
bunch of games with these IP otherwise
why would they be going for these
Acquisitions my optimism has never been
more misguided embracer group has
cancelled a DSX game that's been in
development for 2 years and laid off a
number of employees at the same time as
is the continuing video game Trends in
case you missed it somehow Microsoft has
also laid off 1,900 stop members to
video game Workforce following the $69
billion acquisition from Activision
Blizzard this is both standard and
predictable but still incredibly sad
especially when it keeps coming after
these video game companies are bragging
about their earnings like it's just so
disheartening